he hasn't prosecuted muggers robbers
carjackers murderers rapists the people
actually terrorizing his City and
causing immeasurable harm to the people
who live there that's not any of that
because he's been saving all of his
energy to bring Donald Trump to justice
for supposedly giving some money to some
floozy it's a joke but it's not a funny
one because there's nothing funny about
a dying Republic and this is what
happens in a dying Republic we are
witnessing before our eyes the late
stages of a civilization this is
actually an attack on our democracy it's
hard to imagine a more serious attack
than this trying to win an election by
throwing your opponent in prison if you
want to attack democracy that's how you
do it and it's happening at the hands of
people who of course claim to be
democracy's greatest Champions nothing
could possibly help Donald Trump's
primary campaign more than this and his
coming mug shot photo and when that
photo is is uh is taken and released
just on its own becomes one of the most
powerful and compelling images in the
history of American politics